i want to start today with some rare
good news when it comes to just the
process of voting in the united states
you know we're
waiting to see
whether democrats will be able to push
forward the voting rights bill that joe
biden has been talking about now
intensely for the last week or so
but absent that there are so many
different ways in which republicans are
not even fighting the so-called battle
of ideas which they claim to prioritize
and instead
fighting to win elections by subterfuge
and deception
and systems control rather than winning
people's hearts and minds so
gerrymandering is one of these ways
that republicans have sought to and have
benefited from
uh manipulating the system reducing
ballot boxes in minority neighborhoods
limiting voting hours trying to stop
mail-in ballots mandating specific ids
including ids that
require that while themselves may be
free
required documents which if you don't
have them are not free to obtain
putting in place partisan actors to
oversee
the count or whatever the case may be
it's relentless it's exhausting and the
first element of that that i mentioned
is gerrymandering and we have you know
you've got to look at this big battle
uh or this big war and the different
battles within it
within the battle around gerrymandering
we have a little bit of good news in one
of those sub-battles and that news is
that the ohio supreme court has decided
to throw into the trash
the republican gerrymandered maps and
has given 10 days 10 days to fix it the
ap reporting the ohio supreme court
declared republican-drawn legislative
maps invalid wednesday yesterday
agreeing with voting rights advocates
that the lines were
unconstitutionally gerrymandered
in a 4-3 ruling the court sent the maps
back to the ohio redistricting
commission to take another crack at
complying with provisions of a 2015
state constitutional amendment which
requires there be an attempt at avoiding
partisan favoritism
these maps in ohio are so gerrymandered
that there isn't even evidence that they
tried to avoid partisan favoritism
justices gave the panel 10 days and
retained jurisdiction to review the
handiwork
the dispute comes amid the process of
redrawing legislative and congressional
district maps that states must undertake
once a decade to reflect changes from
the u.s census there's a bunch of
interesting elements here one of which
is
republican governor mike dewine a member
of the commission and whose son was
among wednesday's dissenting justices
pledged in a statement to work with my
fellow redistricting commission members
on revised maps
think about that
republican mike dewine is a member of
the redistricting commission
and his son is one of the justices on
the supreme court who said the maps are
fine that's my dad was involved in in in
drawing and writing it i mean it's it's
you know
there are so many ways in which this is
just absolutely insane
and you've got to fight these battles
one by one and this is the difficulty
when they have so many ways you know
they talk about winning the battle of
ideas
and the problem is they've lost the
battle of ideas when you look at the
country and you say
do most people believe that the
government has a basic duty to provide
some health care to everybody regardless
of ability to pay very popular statement
not reflected in our elected officials
not reflected in uh the actions of our
elected officials when you say well
what's the position on abortion
nationally well
legal in most cases is the opinion of
more people than ever before in the
united states is that reflected in our
elected officials no
they're not winning people over in terms
of hearts and minds and policy they're
winning with gerrymandering making
voting difficult for the people that
they think would be to their advantage
to make voting difficult for
all of the other things that i mentioned
and then when you even take the war
and then you look at one battle
gerrymandering and you look at that
battle in one state ohio you find oh one
of the guys who was involved in drawing
these lines which are crazy partisan was
mike dewine
and one of the justices on the ohio
supreme court deciding as to whether
those lines are okay or not
is the son of mike dewine it it's just
it's truly stunning that this is what's
going on in this country but it is and
so we've got to fight these battles one
by one the battle
it's not even that it's been won yet in
ohio there's the opportunity to win it
by getting more fair maps drawn they
have ten days to do it now nine since
the decision was yesterday we'll follow
it and we'll let you know what happens
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian
eating a more plant-based diet is a
really great thing to do for a number of
different reasons and our sponsor just
egg is the delicious plant-based egg you
can use it anywhere you use traditional
eggs because the taste and texture are
identical but just egg plant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs i use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelets you can make
quiche frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg
i was surprised that a plant-based egg
could both taste and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious